mark zuckerberg is on a vr spending
spree i'm not sure folks realize like
like facebook's largest expenditure for
multiple years now has been vr we don't
know exactly how much facebook is
spending but most people think it's
around five billion dollars per year and
that's after they spent two billion
dollars to buy oculus in 2014 it's now
seven years later and vr still hasn't
reached mass adoption the average use
for a virtual reality had the average
number of times people use a virtual
reality headset is one don't get me
wrong vr is an amazing technology but it
just hasn't gotten to the point where
average people can enjoy it every single
day but zuckerberg isn't taking his foot
off the gas he now has 20 of facebook's
employees working on vr in some capacity
it's a massive investment that sounds
way out of line with the current market
opportunity both oculus and instagram
were acquired around the same time for
around the same price but instagram
brings in more than 10 times as much
money for facebook as oculus and at a
much higher margin so why is zuck still
so obsessed with vr well there are a few
different reasons but to understand them
we need to talk about the metaverse so
let's put on our vr headsets and dive in
what is the metaverse you know it's a
virtual environment where you can be
present with people in digital spaces
kind of think about this as an embodied
internet that you're inside of rather
than just looking at and we believe that
this is going to be the successor to the
mobile internet
for the past few months everyone in tech
has been talking about the metaverse
non-stop there are lots of different
definitions floating around out there
but no one has done more work to
popularize the term metaverse than
matthew ball the best way to think about
it is a quasi-successor state to today's
mobile internet in much the same way
today's mobile internet built off of the
internet of the 90s and 2000s lots of
people especially engineers are
extremely skeptical when a business
blogger comes along and coins a phrase
for a vague collection of technology
trends but sometimes these terms do have
a practical use think about how we label
generations terms like boomer millennial
and gen z are all loosely defined around
a period of dates we can't all
completely agree upon people typically
use the birth years between 1981 and
1996 to define the millennial generation
but is someone born on january 1st of
1997 all that different from a
millennial obviously not but that
doesn't mean that there isn't value in
having a term to describe a new era
technology has been through a few of
these and sometimes they are only clear
in hindsight after mainframe computers
were adopted by corporations the
personal computing era brought
technology into the homes of millions of
people it wasn't long before these
computers were connected to the internet
which marked the beginning of the
dot-com era and the last 15 years have
clearly been defined by the mobile phone
each era of computing has had huge
winners but no one company can bring
about a new era alone and that's why the
metaverse is such a useful concept it's
not just fortnite or vr or crypto the
metaverse is an idea that ties these
concepts together and seeks to explain
how they all interconnect so you're
probably wondering how will the
metaverse be any different from today's
internet fortunately matthew ball has
laid out a few key ideas that highlight
what this evolved form of the internet
will look like first the metaverse will
be persistent meaning that it never
resets pauses or ends massively
multiplayer online role playing games
are the closest thing that we have to
this currently but not many other online
experiences replicate this well when you
win a match in fortnight the map resets
entirely and anything you built in that
game is gone forever second the
metaverse will be live much of the
modern internet is built for
asynchronous use you can watch this
youtube video at any time for example
and pre-scheduled events will take place
in the metaverse for sure but everything
will be designed to be live by default
third experiences will span both digital
and physical worlds pokemon go was the
first massively adopted augmented
reality game and that gives us a preview
of what's to come this theme isn't
restricted to gaming specifically though
microsoft is already helping companies
build digital twins that represent
physical infrastructure in virtual
spaces here's microsoft's ceo to explain
what that means with azure digital twins
you can model any asset or place with
azure iot and keep the digital twin live
and up to date synapse tracks the
history of digital twins and finds
insights to predict future states and
with azure you can build autonomous
systems that continually learn and
improve fourth there will be no cap on
concurrent users this is one of the
hardest problems to solve from a
technical point of view but it's
critical even the biggest online games
still restrict each session to around
100 players even though millions might
be playing at a given time worldwide a
single server will still be capped
massive concurrency will make metaverse
experiences feel very different from the
present day internet fifth the metaverse
will have a fully functioning economy
increasingly the internet is simply the
best place to make money nearly every
business has moved online now but
there's still a long way to go until we
have a fully digitally native economy
most transactions are still siloed in
particular virtual spaces an investment
in digital goods is still in its infancy
sixth the metaverse will have
unprecedented interoperability this
means being able to bring a fortnight
skin into minecraft and vice versa tim
sweeney who founded epic games and owns
fortnite has been talking about this for
years now and it's clearly an important
goal these days most internet products
are walled gardens and users have no
real way of moving data items content or
currencies between services lastly user
generated content will play a massive
role in the metaverse this is basically
a requirement since no single company
could ever hope to produce enough
variation in their games to satisfy
everyone roblox and minecraft have been
so successful because community members
create engaging and unique experiences
for each other now you're probably
thinking that those are all pretty
incremental developments and they are
individually none of them are going to
really change anything about how we
experience modern technology but taken
together they can create some pretty
remarkable things when multiple loosely
related technologies start to get better
at the same time there are often
surprising second order effects and
we've seen this exact thing happen
several times in the past consider the
second industrial revolution that
occurred in the late 19th century thomas
edison built the first electric power
stations in 1881 but it wasn't until 40
years later that electricity really
started being used to power machines
that's because factories weren't
designed around electricity when it
became available most plants just
replaced their steam engines with
electrical ones and call it a day this
failed to take advantage of the full
benefit of electrification older
factories were designed to have a single
power source that was either completely
on or completely off this meant that
when the factory was on every machine
was running but electricity can be
routed locally and turned on or off
based on the specific needs of the
moment eventually new factories were
built to take advantage of the true
value of electricity and productivity
soared henry ford built the first moving
assembly line which cut the production
time for a single car from over 12 hours
to just 93 minutes this was only
possible because electricity was
available everywhere throughout the
plant and the factory could be designed
for maximum efficiency we tend to think
of thomas edison as single-handedly
bringing about the electrification of
america it was literally a light bulb
moment but that narrative completely
ignores the advances in power management
manufacturing hardware and production
theory that collectively led to the real
impact of electrification that's why
treating the metaverse as just vr is so
wrong vr might be a foundational
metaverse technology but as we've seen
it's clearly not enough we've had decent
vr headsets for years now but no
metaverse if thomas edison is a little
old school for you don't worry we can
learn all the same lessons from steve
jobs and the iphone most people will
point to the iphone as the beginning of
the mobile internet era and just like
the light bulb they aren't wrong but the
full story is much more complex even
though the first iphone did have a web
browser it didn't have a 3g modem and
most websites had yet to be optimized
for mobile so the experience was pretty
bad it wasn't until the second iphone
that the mobile internet really started
taking off and even then this was almost
a full decade after the wireless
application protocol created the
standards that allowed phones to access
the internet in the first place
obviously there were lots of internet
connected mobile devices before the
iphone and the impact of mobile wasn't
entirely clear until apps like instagram
and uber created businesses that
couldn't exist before the idea of a
supercomputer in your pocket has been
alluring for decades in 1976 the sci-fi
author arthur c clarke published
imperial earth in the book he described
a mobile video phone called the mini sec
which had global data connectivity and
sounds an awful lot like the iphone and
in the 90s a team of engineers spun out
of apple to start a new company called
general magic the goal of that company
was to basically create an iphone but
they had to build everything from
scratch and went bankrupt before
launching it
the iphone was only possible because so
many other technological visions had
finally become realities steve jobs
deserves all the credit in the world for
the iphone but it was only possible
because other entrepreneurs had built
foundational technologies first screen
manufacturers made the iphone durable
chip designers made the iphone powerful
and app developers made the iphone
useful the iphone was the culmination of
dozens of different independent
technologies working together to produce
a truly revolutionary product investors
often talk about the iphone moment as a
key turning point in any new technology
it's the point where everything comes
together and really starts working and
it often marks the dawn of a new era in
some ways the light bulb moment and the
iphone moment couldn't be more different
the light bulb was merely an idea that
sparked decades of innovation but it
didn't have immediate consumer value the
iphone on the other hand was not just a
single idea it was the synthesis of
dozens of technological trends and
that's how you should think about the
metaverse it certainly hasn't had an
iphone moment yet but there may have
been a light bulb moment even though we
can't quite put our finger on it yet in
a few years we might point to the oculus
fortnite or ethereum as the true
beginning of the metaverse but that
won't matter as much as what comes next
the iphone moment for the metaverse will
only come after we have made significant
progress in several key areas of
technology computers need to get faster
in order to support more realistic
rendering and physics calculations it's
no coincidence that the biggest games
all have the most simplistic graphics
fortnite roblox and minecraft are all
designed to run on basically any device
so they have to be simple internet
connections also need to get a lot
stronger for the metaverse to really
work netflix is able to stream you hd
video content because they can compress
the footage you're watching in advance
and store the file on a server in your
region we've all seen how difficult it
is to maintain a stable connection even
on a basic video call and i wouldn't
call zoom an immersive experience most
video calls are 720p highly compressed
and 24 frames per second at best in
order for vr to feel immersive you
usually need two separate streams of
near 4k video running at 120 frames per
second if internet connections get
faster the content you're viewing in vr
could be rendered on a server and then
stream to you like how google stadia
runs games in the cloud and just sends
you the resulting video feed so hardware
will need to get better and smaller but
that actually might be the easy part see
computers basically get better every
year but the networks built on top of
those computers only get more
complicated intertwined and entrenched
the real promise of the metaverse is one
of universality it's right there in the
name the verse in metaverse only works
if we develop a full-fledged world that
is open to anyone and encompasses
everything big tech is in an interesting
position right now they want to help the
metaverse become a reality but only as
long as it doesn't challenge their
dominance the reason that zuckerberg is
investing so heavily in the metaverse
right now is because facebook has by far
the largest user base of any tech
company 3.5 billion people already use
facebook that's half of everyone on
earth and all those people are creating
and consuming content through facebook
apps already this is a massive head
start for facebook which is why
zuckerberg is happy to invest billions
of dollars to make sure facebook
maintains a dominant position in what
comes next but facebook has stiff
competition one of the cornerstones of
the metaverse will undoubtedly be
payments infrastructure the ability to
buy sell and most importantly actually
own things in the metaverse could be the
most transformative part of this new era
facebook hasn't really been able to
crack payments yet but crypto certainly
has the biggest gripe that most people
have with facebook is that it's
essentially controlled by a single
person crypto still has a lot of work to
do if the plan is to defeat facebook but
metaverse-like projects are already
starting to gain traction although they
are extremely small at the moment even
though metaverse related crypto projects
are still in their infancy it's totally
possible that one of these projects
winds up being the biggest winner
instead of an existing tech company as
we saw with the mobile internet era
there were tons of big winners but apple
was probably the biggest winner of all
even though apple had been around for
decades they were in the right place at
the right time and executed perfectly
facebook wants to build something so
fundamental to the metaverse that they
can capture that iphone moment and if
they succeed the billions they've
invested will look like pennies all of
this barely scratches the surface of
what's going on with the metaverse so
please subscribe for future videos
thanks for watching